everyone goes to the movies for
different reasons some people like just
pure escapism while others want to be
intellectually stimulated or have a good
laugh however nobody goes to the movies
because they just want to be totally
confused which is a major problem when
it comes to these six movies that still
don't make any sense to people until now
trance this Danny Boyle picture didn't
make a huge impression on moviegoers
when it came out with a twisty heist
plot one reviewer noted as purposely
convoluted and impossible to keep up
with it doesn't help that the movie
plays fast and loose with the bounds of
reality particularly with the concept of
therapeutic hypnosis a real thing that
the film portrays as something closer to
sorcery than science but it turns out
that under all that intentional
confusion the film's plot is actually
really straightforward Elizabeth the
therapist played by rosario Dawson was
behind the arts high central to the
movie see she once was in an ill-fated
relationship with Simon played by James
McAvoy in using hypnosis to make Simon
forget their relationship she also been
planted the idea of an art heist in his
mind drawing the attempt to recall
Simon's memories
Elizabeth forms a brief relationship
with a Vincent Casals criminal boss
Frank but he ends up as manipulated as
everyone else by Elizabeth an
unbelievably smart puppet master who was
willing to let a lot of people die to
get her hands on some money it all makes
sense now
right Synecdoche New York it's no
exaggeration to say that 2008 Synecdoche
New York is a movie about everything and
everyone as Roger Ebert noted in his
laudatory review it's a story about you
whoever you are a sprawling
ever-changing cast which features
different actors playing the same
characters in the production over the
course of decades speaks to the essence
of identity how was seen and perceived
as we perform our roles in life with our
small successes painful failures and the
major flaws Caden Cotard played by
Philip Seymour Hoffman is an artist
obsessed with creating the perfect
artwork and accomplishing the goal is
just as impossible as living a perfect
life no one can do it and we will all
die trying the key to understanding
works by Charlie Kaufman described
behind cinematic Mindbenders such as
Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind
and Being John Malkovich is that there's
no distinction between the dream world
and reality everything is real exist
thing together in a surrealistic stew
and the impossible aspects of the movie
represent real feelings very little in
his films a literal but everything feels
true Solaris in Steven Soderbergh's
2002 mind bender Solaris a Space Station
hovers over a mysterious ocean planet
which despite decades of research has
remained that knowable to its observers
worse the only data scientists on earth
have received from the station has been
borderline nonsensical and eyewitness
reports of impossible beings on the
planet's surface from people who have
been there or dismissed as
hallucinations Chris a psychologist from
Earth makes a journey to Solaris to
examine the state of the crew and decide
if observations should continue but upon
arrival he too begins to experience
impossible phenomena including
visitations from the Phantom of his long
dead wife somehow miraculously revived
at the end of the film a chris is
visited by the apparition of a child
when he takes a child's hand Chris seems
to suddenly be back at home on earth
with his wife alive for saitm only then
we see the surface of Solaris and the
film ends so what the heck happened that
he died in become one of the planet's
phantasms is he alive on Solaris living
in a fantasy world did he actually gets
sent home somehow it's up to you as a
viewer to decide do you understand what
I'm trying to tell you there are no
answers only choices demon a highly
regarded 2015 polish horror picture
follows an English groom as he arrives
in his fiance's native Poland for a
grand wedding before her gathered family
after an encounter in the yard with a
bird skeleton the protagonists emotional
state and the sanity starts to fray he's
haunted by visions and possessed by a
dead woman who wants to live in love
again her takeover of his body
culminating in his utter break down as a
family presses on with the ceremony near
the end one family member mentions that
the husband is gone and indeed he never
appears again and the movie ends quietly
soon after but what does this mean did
he vanish of his own accord was he taken
by the demon or did the wife's family do
him in to be rid of him there are no
answers in this anticlimax the family's
response though is clear raised over the
wedding site forget this ever happened
but it struck in a lake and pretend he
was never here the film seems to be a
metaphor for post-war wounds and the
distress sowed by nationalism
you can vary the pastel you once but
your history will always find a way to
resurface it just might not make any
sense when it does upstream color if you
were confused by the
critically-acclaimed 2013 indie film
upstream color don't worry because we're
going to explain it as simply as
possible Chris is infected by a parasite
that plugs her into a shared
consciousness putting her in a
suggestible state that leads her to
destroy her life drawn to a pig farmer
who uses music to attract the parasites
chris has the parasite removed it is
then placed in pigs who are chucked into
the river to drown after they die the
parasites infect all kids leading to
larvae which are harvested to create new
parasites which are used to infect more
people and expand the shared emotional
network even further Chris and Jeff
another former hosts interrupt this
process by killing the farmer they then
gather the rest of the victims of the
farm and form a new community breaking
the cycle of trauma
the film is essentially an extended
metaphor for human emotional
connectivity simple see arrival at the
end of the acclaimed 2016 sci-fi drama
arrival alien visitors patiently explain
the whole movie to their human
interpreter Louie is played by Amy Adams
despite this though many fans left the
theater still scratching their heads why
well it turned out those flashbacks
showing the loss of Louise's younger
daughter weren't flashbacks at all but
visions of Louise's tragic future the
mind-blowing twist was confusing enough
for some fans that a large portion of
the Internet was devoted to explaining
it a process that clearly is still
ongoing
[Music]